foreign
all right so uh hold on one second then
I'm trying to get something to work here
okay we well welcome to a
well from language design review about
words and language which means human
language
uh there's still a thing
um hold on one second I need to make
something work uh
um
okay all right so
I think in the in the vein of clearing
out old chestnuts and a lot of things
that are in varying states of completion
and review from a lot of different word
and language related domains
there's a lot of stuff here so there is
uh the uh overhaul of word data
splitting entities into word and Word
Sense entities there are also phrase and
phrase sense entities and we need to
talk about kind of how we handle that
right
um there's the the question that still
has been outstanding for a while about
we have a lot of different word lists
and dictionaries that fulfill different
roles in language in different places
yep that are not all synchronized with
each other and some questions about how
we want that to actually be realized yep
um there's also some stuff that's in Dev
mode in just in language data some new
properties new pods in the scanner side
on Alpha side there's a new domain
language family
which is mostly and Christian crew can
say more about this but mostly taking
things that used to be entity classes in
language data and representing them as
Lang as entities in their own right
because they themselves can have
different properties associated with
them and there's a whole hierarchy of
things there
um also some of the design questions
about two grams word frequency and the
kind of phonetic phoneme data stuff that
we've talked about at different times in
the past but still there's there's a
lack of clarity about what we're trying
to accomplish and to get there all right
and a lot of this also kind of got
started before we we entered the
the llm landscape and so there are also
some some questions about whether there
are things we should be trying to use
there or how we account for the rise of
llm related stuff given that that's you
know this space is something where
they're strong
okay
should we dive in yeah I think so
um so one of the things here you know
the the surf word the the word and Word
Sense entities have been set up in the
surf so they're they will behave like
regular entity for the first time
um you know ultimately the thing that we
would like to do is get rid of the old
wdx word data packlet and have
pre-fetched data have actual entities
yes have the data at least there finally
be synchronized with what's in Alpha
because the alpha word data stuff has
had more surgery and additions and
tweaks over the years
um so some of this I think is just
useful to to look at and talk about
the design I mean the the names how the
individual word senses look does this
make sense for us in language I think
the answer is yes this looks good I mean
I think you know I have a minor
objection that should be slightly
lighter gray because I mostly want to
see green yeah but um what is that green
there
that green is a green that doesn't have
a sense tag
um that's that's one of the things that
we've talked about that possibly
right well it's also one of the things
that potentially
um you know an llm might help with
suggesting things to fill in there I
think that ultimately things right I
mean it it works pretty well just in
experimenting with that and those still
will obviously need a human to look over
them but
naming a sunset is something that I
really think another one should be able
to do yeah
and to what extent do we have any hope
of being able to get word frequencies
for these different word meanings
you mean for like at the sense level not
just at the part of speech level that is
correct
here's why I think that's not hopeless
okay I think an llm might be able to do
that because it can know what is its
representation in embedding space of a
green as a piece of land
right it has a representation as it you
know that is an embedding there's some
Vector that represents that meaning
and I don't think it's hopeless to be
able to say in if if we just did the
most basic search then and said you know
how many things are there close to that
place an embedding space
in common cruel let's say that would
give us frequency
and the reason that's useful is clearly
in the case of green it will be very
useful to know which of these are
obscure like I have no idea how ketamine
relates to Green I don't know what I
want to know correct but um you know
that's not a meaning I'd ever heard
before
right whereas green as spectral color is
certainly a very you know a very common
meaning
and I bet we can deduce that
are you thinking are you thinking about
this just at the level of
among word senses their relative
frequency or trying trying to do this
you know this sense in the whole Space
of word senses
um I think well I think relative would
be uh would be necessary I think in the
space of all word senses would be nice
and I bet there are useless for that
okay
but I mean you understand my idea that
basically we find the embedding vector
and each one of these things potentially
one of its properties might be an
embedding vector
okay
see what I'm saying
I mean if we have a standard embedding
now maybe that isn't a good idea maybe
we can't burn that in yet
but if we have a standard embedding then
we can say things like what is the
distance in embedding space from this
word to this from this meaning to this
other meaning
okay
which is very cool if we could do that I
mean that's what we have you know just
to give a sense of how that works let me
just remind people what does everybody
understand how this all works
nobody understands should I remind
people it wouldn't wouldn't hurt if you
can do a quick demo I think or something
let's let's do something here
um
and the chat gbt explainer I had some
stuff about this
uh
where did I have this
um
someplace here we go here we go this is
a good example
okay so this is the word crane
okay so this is projected embedding
space
crane as in
the wild crane was born at this time
this is in the railway cranes
okay
so I don't know quite how we represent
this but this is like the center of the
wild cranes is up here the center of the
Railway cranes is down here
if you get what I'm saying
yeah
um
and and in general
you know we know
in
overall embedding space that's just a
two-dimensional projection of embedding
space
I I kind of think this is useful I mean
I I don't know who would be the best
person outside of this group to talk
about
trying to determine on the machine
learning people great
okay but I I like this a lot
okay this is good good
I mean property is similar I mean this
this would be just updating things so
that we're we have something that's more
typical of of what we currently do I
mean I think like other packlets that
we've updated if we're just talking
about the word data function right we
can have a legacy method that lets
people get the old
stuff if they have code that's expecting
these
I mean I don't understand why in this
case by the time we're doing definitions
I don't know why we don't have a list of
definitions here I mean this is
um it's it's also just kind of a naming
difference right because the the old
word data is just this is something
we'll have to account for too I'm I'm
faking this
this because we have two different
entity types that are feeding in here
that have
the singular versus plural definition
properties for now I think we would
standardize that just to definitions
yeah fine but I'm sorry when you're when
you're well when you're talking about a
a specific sense you're only going to
have one definition
I understand that I'm just saying that
on the right hand side here I'm saying
this should be a list instead of having
a semicolon there
break the definitions
yeah but I mean those aren't those
aren't multiple definitions like if that
was in a dictionary that would be that
would be the definition
I know but but I mean you want to you
want to split things up like that I see
you're saying this is a single thought
yeah yes okay you're you're right in
this case okay you're right you're right
so your basic claim is that anytime it's
a single word sense there's a single
thought for the definition
yes
okay I bet that's right
okay
um
Sandra is asking our live stream would
would data Dictionary look up and word
list all be the same I think we're about
to get to that we're not there yet that
is where we're going but we're not there
yet let's we'll talk about that in a
moment
um
and just to compare this is sort of the
the chaos that you get with
trying to get all the properties for
a word in word data American spelling
better be not missing not available it
better just be green
yeah it can be and a lot of the the
that's another question that I had here
because we've you know the uh the old
design and word data was
listing all of the senses and then you
know empty list if there is no value for
that sense for all of these things right
now this is just kind of getting
flattened out where if there's there's
not a specific value for some of these
other properties
do we want it to collapse down to just
you know it's missing for everything or
do we want to always return an
association of
okay so the issue is some of these
things
and sorry for spelling I agree like that
that's at the at the head Word level
there's no reason that that shouldn't be
populated with right an anagram for
everything yeah you know just pure
whatever it is yeah so I think there are
two categories here there are things
that are fundamentally properties of
senses and those things that are
fundamentally properties of the
essentially morphology of the word
right
right so I mean this word let's talk
about I mean in terms of the standards
of linguistic classification of you know
we've got the morphological stuff we've
got the um uh we've got the syntactic
stuff for words like what part of well
and not part of speech we can't yet do
until we have word sensors right then
then we get to uh
you know so I mean I I think we yeah I
think I think we should just decide for
every property is it a Word Sense
property or is it a word morphology
property so to speak
right if it's a Word Sense property I
basically think it has to be broken into
all its senses
always even if even if they are all we
don't have a value for that property for
that particular word for any of the
senses still return an association with
a bunch of missings I think so well it
wouldn't be necessarily missing I mean
like inflected forms
isn't it just a null list when it
doesn't have one
see what I'm saying
yeah
in the case of inflected forms it's got
to be an inflection
you know that's got to be an association
of what the inflection is so to speak
which by the way the llms do brilliantly
we'll get to that further below too
yeah he's going to tell me they're not
as brilliant as I think they are no no
no that no actually I think I think
generally you're right I mean but that's
a that's a a level of detail that we
haven't gotten from other
structured sources to date and it is
something that I think they do well and
it's it's another tool to flesh that out
and so the question is
how do we want to break those out like
we're gonna standardize and have
associations of
specific named inflections and their
values for each thing right so what I
think here is
that the generation of a complete dump
of everything can be quite large and
that
we should really aim for as much
rectangularity in what we're generating
as possible
okay even if it's big and even if
something's a missing I just think there
should be an expectation that you can go
in you get the word sense
you get uh now there may be and we'll
come to this
there may be
I don't think it makes a lot of sense to
ask for the inflections of a word like
green
and
without talking about its part of speech
or its sense or whatever else I I don't
okay here's a question and this is maybe
the syntax layer
given that you know the part of speech
do you know the inflection or do you
need to know the word sense to know the
inflection
um
let's determine that I don't know
yeah my guess is you do not need the
word sense in that case
anybody else want to opine on that
Linguistics oriented folk any up and
ends here yeah so the inflections will
be common to
all senses that share the same part of
speech show a given word that's what I'm
saying that's what I'm claiming which
means that we might want to have
a you know that means we might need an
entity that is green as a verb yeah
that's that question that question had
come up too right
we have people who know about
Linguistics more than I do so we are
going to extend this to other languages
maybe we will need that difference
which difference of inflections being
distinct based on uh yes
okay interesting
yeah I was gonna say I don't see any
immediate problem with it but I I
haven't given it a lot of thought
um okay well let's find out if there's
an example of languages where the the
reflection depends on the sense
um
okay but but
that still makes us want to have a an
entity class that is green as an
adjective for example right
which I think makes sense
well we can I mean we can represent that
I mean it's the kind of thing that
because we've factored this out this way
you can have an implicit density class
or implicit entity that is
green and you know part of speech I
guess it's just a question of whether we
want a unnamed
stored my identity in the database yeah
my guess is we will because I think
particularly when we
uh you know for example we can
absolutely so here's an example of
something I'm sorry but I mean that that
actually that would be the thing that
that would let us align directly to
things like the you know the current
engrams data because that's the the
level of frequency that we get right so
here's a very cool function that we
should have
which is an llm based function that
basically takes a sentence and takes
every word and replaces it by its word
sunsanity
interesting which it should be able to
do
and moreover we should be able to
replace every word eventually by its
fully inflected you know by its
inflection description and so on as well
and again the llm should be able to do
that
so then actually that so there's a
there's a use case that maybe answers a
question that I had further down which
is
right now and sort of historically with
word data we haven't necessarily had uh
I mean they weren't entities but for
let's call them entities that all the
the entries in word data
we didn't have one that represented
every plural form and inflected form of
every word and we would if you queried
for
and I think I have an example further
down below of something it's a plural of
something or some inflected form of
something we would just canonicalize it
to the base form and we'd return data
for the base form yeah we want we want
to have a decoration an entity well
uh a decorator or do we want to have an
entity for
eign
entities for every weird inflected form
and by the time we're doing it in
ethical every word is going to get
multiplied by 60 or something for the
number of uh you know tenses or whatever
I don't think we want this for the most
part the day the data associated with
the things would be you know a
definition would just be it's the plural
form of this it's the well the plural
adverse person whatever well right but
but the way I mean it's like Geo variant
something like geovariant it's a wrapper
that essentially commutes with a
definition that is if we say if it's a
word if it's the word
um
green as a verb okay
um you know we do not want a separate
entity for will he will have been
greened
okay which probably has occurred like
three times on the whole web or
something you know what I'm saying right
um so but the whole point is he will
have been greened if we say what does
the you know we want a a definition or
something like that of that what we
really want to do is commute the
definition inside the will have been
you know whatever that is future perfect
or whatever it is right designate her
right so if we have a rapper that means
future perfect
means you know
I don't know what it is it means third
person singular you know masculine
whatever future perfect
thing of this word sense of then I think
we're in good shape
and then because then that can be
factored out and I believe that that's
kind of one of the meta messages of
linguistics is that such factoring makes
sense
I mean it could be the case that is
that's an interesting sort of
theoretical point about Linguistics it's
sort of implicit I suppose that you can
Factor tenses you know
uh you know um number you know plurals
versus whatever you know cases and in
the in languages that have that and so
on that you can Factor lives
which is not obvious but we might as
well use that fact that it is a it is an
assumption of linguistics that you can
Factor those things I claim I don't know
if anybody else wants to agree or
disagree with that statement
go ahead uh sorry one or two things this
brings to mind for me so first of all
um
because
some of these terms are different parts
of speech they will have different forms
so for example some of these will be
able to be modified to Greener but not
all of them so if we you know
type in Greener and look and try and get
all these properties there will only be
a subset of green it will not be
all all of these words so I I think
that's definitely something to keep in
mind I could take that apart for a
second okay so you say if what comes in
is essentially a I don't know what the
general case of the word inflected is
but a a modified form of the green base
word
um then
one very interesting question is
which sensors
what could this be a modification of
because clearly Greener cannot be a
modification of the verb form of green
but it could be a modification of the
adjective form of green
yes and so so okay so that's a good
function that we haven't really
necessarily thought of before which is
given a given explicit you know given a
surface level you know word like greener
what can our symbolic representation
what symbolic representation is that
consistent with so essentially another
way to put this is the following imagine
that you put in a word like Greener okay
imagine you put in green
if you put in green the essentially the
semantic parser will say there are all
these greens that it is in fact we've
got a list pretty much here of those are
the semantic parser will say your green
could be any of those greens
am I making sense but if we type in
Greener the semantic parser is going to
say there are now three possibilities
for that and they all relate to I don't
know like the sick green the um maybe
the unripe green those kinds of things
the gullible green
Etc
right so in other words the semantic
parser is going to return something that
is different depending on what the sort
of uh surface word is does that make
sense to people
and that seems like a reasonable way to
do it as well so okay good point thank
you for that point
um and this sort of ties into one other
thing I don't know if we wanted to get
into the sort of
um word about the world atlas of
language data stuff here if that was
something we were going to get into like
the okay
um so the only comment I had to make
about that is that that could provide us
with a helpful framework to determine
which specific rappers we are working
with and how they function
well wait a minute we're rappers as in
as in like plural or
the way we want right right now that is
a that's a I mean inventorying what can
happen in all the languages of the world
is
worthwhile I mean I you know I think
uh yes I mean I don't know how many I
know like ethical for example has tried
to inventory many of the possible tenses
and I'm sure the world atlas thing has
um has another inventory of possible
tenses
but I mean I know that that you know the
you know quantitative
perfect whatever whatever it is which
may occur in no human language
is a you know you ought to have had you
ought to have had or something like I
I'm not sure I can do it what what that
would be
but um
uh well and the other point is in
English we break all that apart and it's
lots of different words in other
languages
we might uh
you know have all those things stuffed
together so to speak
yeah
yeah I mean I just think it could be a
good starting point I don't know it is
it's important it's important we have to
inventory as much as possible I mean you
know the only thing is we have to make
some base assumptions about how language
works
such as the fact that we can you know
I mean
it is a fact I believe
somewhat surprising fact that the parts
of speech
do actually work the same in all
languages basically
that there aren't
you know fundamentally different parts
of speech now that may just be because
uh uh you know everything we've just got
a hammer and so what we see is nails
so to speak you know in the whistle
languages of the Canary Islands or
something maybe there's a particular
whistle that it's really hard to say
that's an adjective for example but you
nevertheless do that just because we
have adjectives to talk about
look for example in in tokipona for
example this minimal language I believe
there's no distinction between uh nouns
adjectives verbs
hmm
which is similar to
you know I I think I mean that language
it's it's
um you know it's like baby talk type
thing you know I think I think um young
kids don't distinguish in many cases
between uh kind of those different forms
but anyway this is
yeah so yes I agree that that's a really
worthwhile thing and I think it would be
not a crazy idea to start off with some
llm discussion of this because I think
the llm can probably give us you know I
bet if we ask it you know if we say
um
uh
give a list of verb tenses
of
uh give list of all verb tenses
in English
okay
what happens if I say the same thing I
might as command L not work for chat
let's say in anybody get an obscure
language that anybody that anybody who
actually knows
I'm gonna I'm gonna just type in a
language
wow
you tried Japanese as well I'm just
curious if it has variations for
transitive and intransitive also
but those are aren't those moods and
things what are the
oh these do have moods here this one
does have moods
okay yeah so it's not partitioning based
on the form of verb but
okay
well look it's it's clear we can get a
huge amount of useful data here
and we should just go and do these and
try and try and um
uh
I think it's also nice that it can I
mean clearly it can take a word and
you know a base word like walk
we can split up we could spit out a nice
structured
uh list of
events or form to variation
right and by the way I suspect this is
doable by a fairly low level I don't
think you need the fanciest to achieve
this
um
but okay all right fine all right onward
we go so let's take a little look at a
few of these other properties
uh
for logical derivatives I have no idea
what some of these mean and I think we
need to re-look at them because I think
so yeah I think I think so too I mean
we've just pulled things from the old
version and so there's stuff to do here
phrases
phrases is a question so we for the time
being
um Leroy had split out anything that's
uh that's a multi-word
you know a multi-string thing from word
data and those are living as phrases and
phrase sense
um these I think all could be aligned to
phrase entities right now
I've never been crazy about the phrase
type name but haven't come up with a
better
okay so look I've got some comments
about this okay Bowling Green I'm buying
it
okay green frog I'm not buying it
sure okay green dinosaur I'm buying it
even less
in other words
there are things where things where
they're clearly just somebody slapped an
adjective on a
yeah
another thing yeah yeah what where where
there is a factoring of meaning in other
words you know isn't it the case that
one of the features of language I mean
this kind of compositionality idea for
language
which is
you know you can put things together and
together they mean something which is
the together meaning so to speak and
then there are things which don't work
that way like a Bowling Green
I don't think
well maybe there's a notion of a green
well I I don't I don't even know what a
Bowling Green is so maybe I shouldn't um
uh clearly a Green Beret which is
somewhat a proper noun
has is not the same thing as a beret
that happens to be green
you see what I'm saying yeah of course
uh
but a smooth green snake I strongly
suspect there's a snake that happens to
be smooth and green
and a green-eyed monster
is surely
or green eyed is somebody who has eyes
that happen to be green
I bet yeah I mean I think it's green
eyed has yeah Green Knight has a has a
connotation of envy and I'm looking at
Green dinosaur and apparently green
dinosaur is actually a a term like
referring to a living fossil or
so-called green dinosaur oh okay okay
okay so some of these things that seem a
little nonsensical I mean but it's worth
reviewing some of those okay
it should be phrase entities okay if
they are non okay the definition is
okay uh you know and I bet we can ask
another on this right given this thing
is this compositional or is it not yeah
okay so so but if green dinosaur is a
phrase
I mean I'm a little worried that you
know we've got forty thousand fifty
thousand words in English for example by
the time we have these phrases how many
more are there
I don't know
yeah well so I mean
we have to worry about that
and uh uh okay but it's
and I think it is of of decreasing
importance now the only thing that
worries me
let's take you know French for example I
don't know where you know silver play
is quotes the word for please
right but it's multiple words right
how are we dealing with that well
there's got to be English give me an
English example of that
um
uh gosh the surely English examples
but but for it for any reason you have
all these verbs that are compound verbs
like pick up catch up
I see
and then
yeah okay so but then you have weird
things like weblog
well actually I had one you know the
ones that are hyphenated and might not
be like I had one yesterday
co-found oh yeah
um
which looks really weird smooshed
but nevertheless Me Like Somebody
misspelled confound yeah yeah yeah right
so
you know but you know my principle most
words smoosh so we should you know
smoosh as the future so to speak
but I think and and then the question is
what hyphenated words versus
um
you know like purplish green here you
know is that or red green
it's complicated
um
you know I know my friend Chris Cole has
thought about this endlessly we might we
might try asking him some
something about this uh and he's he's
tried to figure out his favorite example
is air vent
is advent you know it's not in
dictionaries apparently
yet it's clearly a word in some sense
but in what sense is it a word
we've got corners of this whole business
but we've clearly got a lot of stuff
that isn't to Corners so to speak
yeah
okay uh
I don't understand how superset comes
can be missing not available I mean it's
a color for goodness sake
just because it's another one of these
things that we can also fill in it's
stuff where there's
yeah there's stuff like that
I mean that's crazy too
written frequency is exactly this so how
could we have a written Rank and not a
written frequency
uh old frequency things I don't know
what the where that stuff came from the
the word frequency per year is the stuff
that we've got from our own engrams
database that the written frequency
written rank Things Are okay I don't
even know all right let's keep going
we're we're
what's all this uh just at the word
sense level same mostly the same set of
prep none of the none of the things that
are only word level with things that are
specific to the the scent
I guess there's a question here about
whether we want to push things down to
the sense level and duplicate them there
like like American spelling is a good
case
you want that to live only at the word
level or do you want to also duplicate
those down to the sense right don't know
you know I kind of like keeping them at
the word level to more clearly
but is it correct or are there senses in
which it is
you know what I'll give you an example
between British I'm pretty sure in sure
i n s u r e versus e-n-s-u-r-e
if you say
in American right you would still
I think you you still have the en form
in American don't you or not yes yes the
okay I'm pretty sure there are some
examples
where the American form is degenerate so
to speak
where it's distinguished in the British
form and not in the American form
so what for us what does that mean that
means
I see that means for a certain word
sense in America since we're basing our
words on the American spellings
well again somebody's got to answer that
I don't know the answer yeah yeah that's
good we can we can see if we can find
some examples of that
but I mean we we have to have certain
assumptions about language and it could
be that it's good enough like this
compositionality assumptions are
you know or Everything is Everything has
some part of speech for example there
aren't words
again I don't know what happens in
languages with whistles and things
whether there can be things that are
I believe everything is is bucket into
parts of speech is that is that a true
statement from linguistically oriented
folk here
in other words that if you take
tonal languages for example those are
like diacritical marks is that true I
mean they're treated that way they're
not treated as a a tone on its own means
something is that true
yes I believe that's true
generally yeah
although here's a weird case Okay a
question mark
on its own
punctuation what is that
because that's a disembodied that's a
thing for which we have no
representation in our you know in word
data question mark doesn't mean anything
that isn't a thing word data
but I have to say I'm I'm
questioning whether there might be
languages in which diacritical marks
meets punctuation
yeah I mean you know Mandarin Chinese is
a classic example where you have
basically a suffix on a sentence that
turns it into a question
like we do in English
yeah but it's not a situation it's it's
not actually a question mark it is a
linguistic you know you would
add basically
a a single syllable
word at the end that makes it a question
or the same the same is done for past
tense you know
Mandarin Chinese is not a heavily
inflected language it tends to use
things that bridge between diacritics
and Standalone words to communicate
tense or to communicate conjugation okay
so what is that what is the part of
speech of the word that is the thing
that questionizes the sentence
so look I don't know if the top of my
head
and you're gonna have to add question
eyes to the spelling dictionary now
so
by the way we include for example the
question mark As in more frequency data
so that includes inflation characters
too
really hmm
right and they are classified as part of
a speech intuition by the way so that's
it's an interrogative word a word that
indicates a question yeah I guess it's
it's a particle but yeah it is because
you can't do that you're not allowed to
do that you know the set of parts of
speech is a fixed set of parts of speech
an interrogative word is interrogative
isn't one of them
in the ordinary
it's because words like who what where
when why and how indicate a question but
they also have a part of speech of their
own right A lot of them are like who is
uh pronoun I believe and you know
you're saying
that if I ask for the word data for who
you're saying what parts of speech show
maybe somebody can do that and I cannot
um
so what I'm saying is that these words
have sort of two different they are both
they're part of speech but they also
indicate a question and that question
indicator is separate from the part of
speech it is a question mark only has a
question indicator it doesn't have that
other thing and I can't remember off the
top of my head like what
I don't know what what all the technical
terms are here but according to the llm
interrogative pronoun is is the term
so it's still a pronoun because it is in
fact a pronoun in English though
in English right in English it is a
pronoun because it is a it is a
placeholder for a noun
yeah well
that's kind of what I'm saying is that
it's almost like
it is a placeholder for a noun and
additionally it indicates a question but
it's part of speech it's a pronoun
yeah a question mark indicates a
question but it it doesn't have that
additional thing that words like who
have that it it doesn't have the same
like grammatical function in a sentence
it just indicates a question it isn't
additionally a pronoun or a noun or a
verb or something
um I forget the technical term for
example but that makes it
hmm
uh
let's see
Dimitri on our live stream suggests
draft dra ught and draft draft
as in beer versus horses
oh yeah
you're right to draft as in a draft in
American is just the raft right
a draft how do you spell a draft beer in
American
e-r-a-f-t okay then we've got an example
here
the word sense breaks differently into
British and America and British you know
the spellings work differently
um
the
so that's an example good example thank
you
um
okay
uh Sandra is commenting on here is the
is it the word order that makes it a
question also
I don't know in some languages I suspect
yes
uh
yeah word order is is something
yeah I mean we're not we're not um we're
not accounted for them again again we
are deeply using
now we have to have an assumption of
compositionality of some kind otherwise
we can't otherwise there's no meaning
you know to
discussing language at the level of
words
so to speak
so I mean okay all right let's keep
going here
um
what's this uh this part kind of we had
some of these third argument things in
word data historically that would
return like the the duplicated flattened
list of values for all of the
things I don't think those were a big
success okay I mean I'm just I'm just
wondering like is there is there utility
in having some property or option or
something somewhere because when you're
working with word data I could imagine
there being cases where you'd I mean you
can just always throw common name at
things and get
the words out I just don't know if
there's sort of value in working with
word stuff where sometimes you're really
not going to want to have all the Yellow
Boxes you're just going to want strings
you don't need the additional
I get it
yeah I mean I was just doing some stuff
with bio sequences yesterday and it was
a little bit frustrating having to say
sequence string all the time right
and in fact that's the thing we should
pin if somebody can take that to the
next bio sequence discussion I want to
bring that up maybe a common name thing
I mean maybe common name just does that
for all of these things just it's I mean
that will work out those words too if
you if you want to get to the words it's
easy enough to just map that over
everything well so long as you know we
have this kind of big big thing somewhat
like normal that is just uh
that um
that seems like a potentially reasonable
way to do it right
and this is just this is just coming
back around to the same discussion we
were having before sort of what what do
we want to do about representing every
different
form of everything and I think you're
saying we
want to go in the direction of having
um yeah symbolic rapper that has for
every word just like we've done in text
structure we have um this kind of thing
that that um
indicates the part of speech and so on
so I think we want to generalize that
and just have some
uh
you know text element like thing that is
a word that is a carrier of lots of
additional annotation data okay
and then just load it up on you know
because we could load it up and it could
say things like
this is in this language this is with
this Locale this is this this whatever
it can have all kinds of information
because I mean for example
uh I don't know too many examples of
this but they're a they're a yeah I'm
gonna ask it
my friendly llm give me a word that
appears in English
French
German
and Swedish
with the same spelling
that is not very
okay
well I I think one example of a word in
every language is taxi right
T is a common example there's only two
different words for T they just get
transmuted into and you mean Tei t-e-a
or chai are the two root words for T in
all languages okay
um
but they might have a different spelling
right yeah and they might have different
transliteration too
I'm just going to make it more difficult
for the llm
that's kind of a lame answer
but amusing
definitely amusing
uh okay but anyway so my point is
each one of these things presumably our
entities are English word
you know fish as in such is the English
word that presumably has to be recorded
in The Entity
right
yes makes sense like so
but it shouldn't appear presumably
well you know somewhat obnoxiously
perhaps
if it's not English it should appear
because our whole system is based on
English
like if this is the word
no you silly llm
you completely didn't understand what I
talked about
no okay
not a lot of points there
uh
okay
um
we're gonna have to tag it somehow right
yeah
I don't know how that's going to work in
terms of the I mean look the fact is in
in the case of a place we'll say
Springfield Massachusetts United States
and we in this case we are We Could Have
Lied we could say it is fish
you know word whatever it is uh fish
well adjective or something uh you know
English and we Allied off and that
that's its canonical form is that entity
with those list of things in it and we
are lied out the English part when we
are treating it you know when we're
yellow boxing it and so on
does that make any sense
not sure just trying to think about
the best way to handle it okay all right
okay let's have a quick look on for some
of these other things sure maybe we can
also this is very you again and yeah we
will need to continue this but but I
mean the fact is that
I think it's really you know we are
doing this you know the fact that we
delayed this for a decade is frustrating
but it has the Silver Lining that we get
to use llms now
which I really think is quite
transformative in terms of making a lot
of things that were you know very
painful
um curation tasks now become rather
straightforward
um
I think it's like Christian right I
think this is this is his
domain here if you want to talk about
what the changes are
oh yeah sure uh so basically in this uh
the difference with this would be
previous specification code the one
that's now in production and it's I mean
you could say that the classification
tree and it's not only looks more nice
because you're trying to go through this
time but now you can see the
classification 3 for uh
for a single entity for example if you
if you just ask in this case for French
and previously and you would only see a
classification tree if you if you ask
for more than two entities you would see
the relationship between them which it's
still something yeah I get it I get it
by the way just a small point I mean in
terms of visual appearance this thing
should be smaller if there are so few
and so few things in it you don't need
this vast space for that tentacle there
small point do you understand what I'm
saying I mean I think there's some Auto
sizing for graphs and it's probably
being ignored for purposes of the
surrendering
um I also think that it's confusing to
have I mean I know that this is pinked
here
um for some reason I don't understand
but but um
um I don't know maybe this is a not a
realistic color coding but I'm just I
think that using the yellow which is the
traditional yellow box thing
um
the uh
uh
for these language groups might not be
the right thing
would you want to reverse it or have a
different scheme
I don't know I mean because I have a
scheme I mean I'm just okay I'm it's
unclear to me let me just take a look at
what happens here
yeah there is like for example in the
case that uh because is that the case in
which two languages have not uh the same
root family and then you've got to say
that you've got to say that explicitly
you can't just show this the the look
it's not clear that we didn't just put
up two results here I mean in in um in
the case of can we see one where they
are related sure yeah
okay and why
is this going down the page and the
other ones are going across the page
it's mostly because uh this uh the other
ones and the you could say the base
trees you just have like a the first two
top levels right like the parent and you
could say the grandparent in this case
yeah you could you go up the root family
which I understand but you can't have it
be inconsistent I mean you could you
could draw this tree and you can render
it nicely so it's a little tiny tree but
it just goes you know down two levels
you shouldn't have so also the thing is
that uh with these trees the basic trees
we also show uh the siblings like when
in these cases they have like
one ceiling right but there are some
cases in which you have a lot of
siblings and when you put it vertically
it looks crowded
how many how worthwhile is it to show 50
siblings or should we just have like we
do in in the tree rendering system now
in the modern tree rendering system we
have a cut off in the number of siblings
and we just have a dot dot dot and we
say how many are missing
I would say uh we have been trying
originally because you're in Telegraph
and it was vertically and I would say we
could handle like three or four siblings
fine but that but then why don't we do
three or four siblings with dot dot I
mean tree now has a specific way of
doing this which is pretty nice
of alighting siblings when there are too
many why don't we use the same thing
if possible just use tree I don't know
whether we're in a position to do that
yet
but use something functionally
equivalent to tree
so I'm saying I just think it's going to
be consistent so you would rather have
all them vertical right that's what I'm
saying I think it's got to be consistent
it's super confusing if some of them are
horizontal and some are vertical and if
we have to lose you know in these cases
we're not explicitly showing the
siblings here which I think is fine
am I making sense
right you understand what I'm saying
something like this also for the
individual cases right that's what I'm
saying and if you want to display the
siblings explicitly do it up to some
number of siblings and then just do
these stubs and if you get too many
stubs then do a dot dot dots with a
number there
makes sense
okay can we get a yes or no you don't
agree you do agree please no so we can
move on make sense okay fine
there
there's nice data here
okay do we have this data yet
like blood ordering things
yeah so we have some we have some there
yeah I already having their the other
and
so we have these instructors and we're
also looking on maybe extracting some
more from walls
okay but now wait a second this this
here
this seems crazy what's being actually
said here in detail because you're
repeating things you know if you say
you know you just say
I don't understand why you need a
left-hand side here the left-hand side
doesn't seem useful
so I'm saying because you're always
going to show a subject to verb and
object a subject to negation of urban
object
making sense
so you don't really need the left hand
side which is just going to repeat the
right hand side
am I making sense do you understand what
I'm saying
yeah uh yeah sure
so you would say like only present the
the values the yeah in this case I would
say and I don't think plus is the right
thing because plus is a commutative
operator and you're specifically trying
to show ordering here okay so I don't
know exactly what the right thing is but
it isn't Plus
um
this needs more review that there's I
mean there's a lot of great stuff here
but I think it needs more of you
what is an inventory size given that
it's
is this what does that mean
what's that number for English
what does it mean inventory size I mean
you have a certain number of consonants
are you saying that there are six
consonants which exist that are rare or
what
Christian do we have the list
definitions actually functioning on
current do we have a definition for all
of the terms from walls
I I'm not sure actually about it and we
could try it we have the distance can
you click the link Stephen I mean this
will work on the on the not not there
the the link to the site
I know what to do it for English which I
actually know
is anything happening or is it dead
not encouraging so far but I mean in
this case for example vowels you know
aeiou in English but why sometimes is
that what this means
hey guys come on you gotta say something
I can't deal with a meeting where you
don't say anything
okay if you're not going to say anything
we've got to move on
um you should
are we Sorry usually things like that
are either for a very rare consonants
um because it it's less referring to the
letters and more the actual sounds so
either there are sounds that only exist
in some dialects okay
um
or there are sounds that are perhaps
slowly disappearing from the language be
due to Accent change and things like
that
um there can be a handful of reasons but
it's it's generally that there is a
consonant that appears in this language
but not in every version of this
language due to pronunciation reasons
fair enough
I'm guessing here but for example in in
Spanish you used to have like ABC and
then there's CH which is a check in in
Spanish and then for example the Double
L used to spend llama it's only it used
to be only one consonant
so I'm guessing that's probably the
difference
I see well but that needs to be
clarified and then then there should be
a list of the actual things
right
right it doesn't make sense
well there's a lot of interesting stuff
here okay
um can I just couple to take for one
second let's look at um
uh
two two topics and then we got a wrap
here
uh one topic is the there's the
harmonization of wordless Dictionary
lookup Etc
do we ultimately think so some of those
have inflections some do not
those kinds of things
uh
what
is our plan with respect to that do we
expect to harmonize those things which
will be nice or do we want to give a
definition I mean like word list should
be capable of giving whatever Dictionary
look up can use am I making sense
yeah I think the case for for Dictionary
lookup and word list
should basically have complete overlap
with each other the differences that
exist are basically bugs or semantic
problems I think the bigger question is
how or whether we want to unify with the
spelling dictionaries
does not have inflective forms by
default it does not include them by
default you can include them with an
option yeah okay fine
um fine and then with an option it will
be equivalent to Dictionary lookup
yes I mean Dictionary lookup basically
just has a static list of words that are
exploded with inflections no I
understand that I understand completely
but I'm saying word list with inflected
forms are a true would give a list
equivalent to the list which is being
used by Dictionary lookup
correct
yes yes when when we unify them that's
what okay so that's the goal there okay
now you you the the other case you were
talking about was
um the spelling dictionary right we have
a dictionary word queue which
unfortunately has a very similar name to
Dictionary lookup which is looking at
the spelling dictionaries the same ones
no idea those were using different
dictionaries yeah
uh so spelling correction list and
dictionary word queue both pull from the
spelling dictionaries
and not from the same resources as word
list or Dictionary lookup
okay and part of that is motivated by
the fact that the spelling dictionaries
need a different structure of dictionary
there is an ongoing question as to
whether we can use the spelling
dictionaries as a Baseline and derive
and fill in everything that's needed for
word list and Dictionary look up from
them because okay let me let me comment
that the world has changed here okay in
the past if we needed to give a
definition for a new word it was a big
pain in the neck in modern times it's
rather easy
right because we just use another lamp
so the fact that we may have some
additional words that are like modern
words that are in the that we've added
to the spelling dictionary but we did
not add to the word list
uh seems like to me like we should try
to we should look at what they are first
of all and then we should try to add
them to the word list to to word list
and to all the word properties
knowing that we will have to fill in
definitions inflections whatever using
llms
am I making sense yeah yeah we can take
a look at the spelling dictionaries and
get a sense of the no I mean you know we
may have added our trade names and
things into the spelling dictionary and
we may want to exclude some words from
the full treatment I mean there may be
proper names in the spelling dictionary
that we don't want to include those
kinds of things right
um
uh
okay let's see the other thing I just
want to cover for one second here
is um
uh the phonetic data stuff
okay
look
um
how many phonemes are there in the world
like a hundred or something
that are traditionally identified
we should absolutely have an entity
you know a um an entity type four
phonemes
which are
if I'm not mistaken I mean that you know
like you say the voiced pharyngeal
fricative and things
well that doesn't that doesn't help us
but
anyway whatever if we get rid of the
parenthesis there we might see a
fricative
um
what the heck is that that's an IPA
representation okay so they're IPA
numbers which are presumably there's a
list of IPA numbers right
and then the question of which language
is
do these
right so the first thing we can
absolutely do
is well they're may not be bored this is
more like American house numbers but not
everything's been allocated
uh
so you know whatever it is a hundred
whatever they are you know labio Dental
approximant or whatever you know there's
there's no reason not to have
an entity type which is all of these IPA
whatever they're called IPA phonemes
basically right
yes
probably aren't some of these aren't
some of these uh
like via critics
IPA
Legacy coding system I see well all
right
three-digit numerical code okay well
fine so then let's use it
you know phonetic entity we can call
them if nothing else if we if we can
find nothing else to call them
all right and sub type things as whether
they're uh critics or a credit card yeah
yeah okay the key voice that's weird
is that
that's an official designation
yes it is
what is it
like vocal fry is it that kind of a
thing or it's like I'm very quicky is
that what it is
I think so I think there are some
languages that use that as part of some
kind of Distinction
you know
yeah
um
okay
so I mean this seems like a no-brainer
to be able to put this in I thought we'd
done this like 15 years ago or something
um I mean I think there's a version in
Dev mode right Alan
yeah there's somebody had done a rough
scrape and and worser but I think that
the main question was you know we're
running up against the
what do we actually want to call it like
phonetic entity seems
generic enough if we're okay with just
having flattened out the consonants
vowels diacritic super segments we'll
say each each individual thing is its
own thing and we and then an IPS can say
something about each of them right and
and they have a Unicode representation
of these IPA things so if we see that we
can map it into the phonetic entity
um
is commenting about
historical origins of words to pull out
not quite sure I understand this
I mean we we have attempted and that's
another thing we should be able to get
from the llms with some degree of
accuracy is um things about etymology of
words
I might have trust issues on that front
but we can try it might make it up right
what is the origin
of the word
apical since I see it on in
what is the origins of well it's just an
llm
I have no Pride with these things
okay
I'm gonna I have to ask this
because this is a word that we have
appropriated for a new meaning
very conveniently it's not corrected by
spelling correctors
okay
who knows
well okay I mean at least you know one
thing that we can at least do in a case
like this we can get it to give more
structured output and at the very least
the question is is its ability to
such that
it will come up with a word it probably
will in that language
I mean honestly it's going to do the
same thing that etymologists are going
to do it's going to say this word looks
like this other word they must be
related
um
anyway okay well we should wrap up here
for now
um
yeah we've got a few details on the the
word side and other places we can we can
do a few more experiments with fleshing
out some of these things and talk about
enumerating all the different inflection
types and everything else come back and
talk about building on that design
right a lot of very nice stuff this is
this is cool and and this is the right
time to be doing this yeah
okay thanks a lot guys thanks to Fox
live stream see you all soon thank you